desde que yo recuerde siempre me ha
gustado la astronomía cuando éramos
chicos y por acá estaba mi hermana para
corroborarlo cuando mi madre
se le acaba la paciencia nos castigaba
poniéndonos cara a la pared yo
frecuentemente escogí a un rincón de la
del cuarto de la televisión donde había
un diccionario larousse y en este
diccionario de la luz había una
ilustración de los planetas del sistema
solar sus distancias al sol me llamaba
mucho la atención en la parte superior
en una zona oscura misteriosa que
estaban situados neptuno y plutón a
miles de millones de kilómetros del sol
serán distancias que yo no podía
asimilar en ese momento distancias mucho
mayores por ejemplo incluso que la
distancia de la tierra al sol
mi madre fue cuando el tiempo
alimentando mi curiosidad con libros en
estos libros descubrí que estas
distancias son diminutas comparadas con
las que hay entre estrellas entre
galaxias en estos libros descubrí que
hay galaxias con cientos de miles de
millones de estrellas ubicadas a miles
de millones de años luz de nosotros el
universo está dominado por escalas que
verdaderamente desafían nuestro
intelecto no deja de sorprenderme a la
fecha que sea posible describir en la
naturaleza mediante modelos matemáticos
usamos leyes físicas las representamos
de manera matemática y esto nos permite
desarrollar ideas estas ideas nos
permiten a su vez ir construyendo
conocimiento nuevo sobre conocimiento
previo el conocimiento que ya se fue
acumulando a lo largo de décadas y de
siglos
y para esto se los quiero ilustrar
platicándoles del observatorio de rayos
gamma
altitud water and cost en el cual he
estado colaborando por los últimos 10
años con alrededor de un centenar de
colegas de méxico-estados unidos hemos
construido junto al pico de orizaba un
detector de 60 millones de litros de
agua cuyo propósito es investigar el
cosmos en particular la naturaleza de
los rayos cósmicos
la historia empieza en 1912 cuando
víctor g se descubre que la tierra es
constantemente bombardeada por un flujo
de partículas provenientes del espacio y
ahora conocemos como los rayos cósmicos
lo que hizo fue elevarse en globos
aerostáticos hasta alcanzar alturas más
allá de los 5.000 metros lo que él fue
observando es que había un tipo de
radiación radiación ionizante que
alteraba que toda la naturaleza de la
materia y que esta radiación iba
aumentando a medida que le iba subiendo
en la atmósfera
dedujo de manera correcta y hay un flujo
de partículas provenientes del espacio y
que la atmósfera las va atenuando
progresivamente en las siguientes
décadas se averiguó que estas partículas
son principalmente núcleos atómicos
núcleos de hidrógeno de helio que viajan
a velocidades increíblemente cercanas a
la velocidad de la luz aceleradas hasta
energías enormes en algún lado del
universo hay objetos que funcionan como
poderosísimos aceleradores de partículas
mucho más potentes que los aceleradores
que hemos construido para entender la
naturaleza de la materia la naturaleza
fundamental de la materia sin embargo no
podemos ver de dónde vienen estas
partículas son partículas cargadas y lo
que sucede cuando una partícula cargada
viaja en un campo magnético como es el
caso de nuestra galaxia que tiene un
campo magnético es que no viajan de
manera rectilínea por eso no podemos ver
exactamente de dónde se originan de la
dirección de arribo no tiene nada que
ver con la dirección donde está la
fuente que la produjo
en los años cincuentas varios
científicos empezaron a especular de
dónde podrían originarse estas estas
partículas enrico fermi en 1949 propuso
que las gigantescas nubes moleculares
donde se forman las estrellas podrían
ser los aceleradores de estas partículas
los aceleradores cósmicos pocos años
después vitaly ginzburg un astrofísico
soviético propuso que las explosiones de
supernova donde una estrella de alta
masa muere de manera cataclísmica
inyectando por la parte exterior de la
estrella serían aceleradores más
eficientes
afortunadamente podemos utilizar la
atmósfera y esto es algo que se fue
descubriendo en los siguientes años
podemos utilizar la atmósfera para el
estudio de las partículas cósmicas
y para esto pues lo que sucede es que
cuando una partícula llega a la parte
alta de la atmósfera desencadena un
chubasco de partículas de menor energía
si el rayo cósmico es absorbido pero la
atmósfera reacciona produciendo
muchísimas partículas que llamamos
partículas secundarias y que pueden ser
detectadas desde diferentes alturas
incidentalmente lo que víctor que se
observó en en sus lobos en sus
mediciones en globo aeroestático era
justamente partículas secundarias en la
atmósfera estas partículas nos sirvieron
originalmente antes de los advenimiento
de los aceleradores para entender la
naturaleza de las partículas elementales
por ejemplo ahí se descubrieron los
muones que son partículas que viven tan
sólo dos millonésimas de segundo pero
gracias a que se propagan muy cerca de
la velocidad la luz hacia abajo ya la
relatividad especial de einstein que
alarga su vida al moverse de manera que
llamamos relativista estas partículas
llegan y están
todos lados de hecho en lo que he estado
hablando han atravesado esta sala aunque
ustedes no los hayan visto alrededor de
100 millones de wones
ahora necesitamos algún trazador alguna
algún tipo de radiación que se mueva en
línea recta para saber dónde se producen
los rayos cósmicos los rayos gamma hacen
justamente esto los rayos gamma son el
tipo más extremo de radiación
electromagnética y es básicamente como
la luz solo que la podríamos calificar
como luz con de esteroides que sólo
puede ser producida por partículas de
muy alta energía si nosotros vemos las
fuentes celestes de rayos gamma aquí
tenemos algunas este podemos ver cuáles
son los estos aceleradores cósmicos y
comprobar si fermi ginsburg tienen razón
y también en el primer cuarto
d
del siglo 20 este papel cherenkov
encontró que la radiación de alta
energía produce un tipo de luz luz azul
en el agua que llamamos hoy en día los
cherenkov esta luz denota el paso de
manera brevísima el paso de partículas
de alta energía en el agua en los años
cincuentas físicos británicos lograron
construir detectores de agua con
sensores de luz
llamamos tubos fotomultiplicadores
algunos de estos sensores que registran
muy rápido estas señales de luz para el
estudio de partículas cósmicas y en 1960
instalaron del primer detector de agua
para el estudio de rayos cósmicos en
habra parc en inglaterra
estos arreglos constan de decenas o
pueden ser cientos de detectores
individuales de agua dispersos en un
área relativamente grande
no podemos muy fácilmente saber si el
chubasco de partículas que inciden en
nuestro arreglo detector se debe a rayo
un rayo cósmico o un rayo gamma pero si
es posible ya en los años ochentas
noventas
lo que quedó claro es que la mejor
oportunidad para distinguir rayos gamma
de los rayos cósmicos era yéndose a muy
mayor altura posible esto hizo que en
1998 una colaboración de instituciones
de eeuu instalará en nuevo méxico a una
altura de 2.600 metros
el observatorio de rayos gamma milagro
que fue capaz de demostrar que era
posible separar los rayos cósmicos y
hacer mapas del cielo observado en rayos
gamma
esta colaboración se acercó a
instituciones mexicanas y nos propuso la
creación de un observatorio más grande y
a una mayor altura que se high altitude
water trankov en el observatorio de
rayos gamma que tenemos hoy en día en el
parque nacional pico de orizaba
hay que decir que méxico es un lugar
privilegiado para la astronomía en
cuanto a su geografía los sitios tanto
en baja california como la
disponibilidad de sitios por encima de
4000 metros donde no se congele el agua
esto sólo es posible en mexico en china
india y el norte de los andes y así
empezamos a trabajar en este
observatorio
el observatorio job en el cual empezamos
a trabajar desde 2006 y empezamos a
instalar en 2010 2011 consta de 300
tanques de agua de gran tamaño son 7
metros de diámetro cada tanque 5 metros
de altura
pueden ver la la escala comparado con la
escala humana cada uno tiene 180 mil
litros de agua el agua se trata para que
sea completamente transparente y pueda
verse la luz tiene como no absorbe la
luz cherenkov que hay y se mantiene en
condiciones de cuarto oscuro como los
cuartos oscuros que en la juventud
veía uno
cada uno de estos tanques está
instrumentado con cuatro tubos
fotomultiplicadores de manera que
tenemos 1200 canales de datos este
observatorio funciona continuamente todo
el día de día y de noche prácticamente
sin interrupción y va captando 20.000
rayos cósmicos por segundo continuamente
generando más de 2 terabytes diarios de
datos
no tenemos una internet muy bueno en el
sitio entonces vamos acumulando decenas
de terabytes de datos allí y finalmente
nos transportamos al instituto de
ciencias nucleares en ciudad
universitaria donde los datos son
posteriormente transmitidos por internet
a la universidad de maryland en estados
unidos creando también una un respaldo
que donde es un respaldo respectivo de
toda esta base de datos
y todos los colaboradores nos están
desde nuestra comodidad de nuestras
oficinas nos conectamos estas
computadoras analizamos los datos usamos
métodos matemáticos de visualización
para primero definir si en una posición
dada hay una fuente de rayos gamma y
para caracterizar la y algunos colegas
usan
métodos particularmente vistosos y así
hemos hecho un mapa de dos terceras
partes del cielo visto con radiación con
este tipo de radiación de muy alta
energía radiación extrema que revela
dónde están los aceleradores cósmicos y
se ve una banda que es el plano de
nuestra galaxia en nuestra galaxia hemos
observado efectivamente remanentes de
supernova como lo predijo en su momento
x bourg y fermín también son las
complejas de formación de estrellas de
ahí de estas nubes moleculares pero
hemos visto también cosas más complejas
estrellas de neutrones a través de
vientos interaccionando con el medio
ambiente y estrellas de alta masa que
tienen poderosos vientos que también
producen rayos cósmicos la naturaleza
tiene más caminos para generar este tipo
de partículas de los que habíamos ido
imaginando y esto es lo que hemos ido
develando con los años
como científicos nos dedicamos a
recopilar datos y estudiarlos por
curiosidad por el afán de entender mejor
la naturaleza
es la curiosidad la que nos guía a la
empresa aparentemente fútil de entender
el cosmos y aquí citando un escrito de
1939 pero todavía vigente del educador
estadounidense abraham flexner es
curioso que en un mundo inundado de
odios irracionales que sacuden a la
sociedad y amenazan incluso a la
civilización misma haya hombres y
mujeres dedicados a desarrollar la
cultura a entender la naturaleza ya
extender el conocimiento mismo flexner
cita que maxwell simplemente por
curiosidad desarrolló las leyes de la
electro dinámica y hertz las empleó para
describir las ondas de radio como ondas
electromagnéticas esto sentó las bases
para las telecomunicaciones a principio
del siglo 20 la misma curiosidad la
misma curiosidad que siente un niño al
ver por primera vez un joven incluso un
adulto al ver por primera vez un eclipse
o la misma curiosidad que sentía yo al
ver esta ilustración del diccionario
larousse
la que yo por ejemplo a max planck a
desarrollar el principio fundamental de
la mecánica cuántica que es la base de
la tecnología de la revolución
tecnológica de los siglos 20 y 21 y
después hay muchos caminos que nos
llevan del conocimiento fundamental que
puede parecer primero superfluo al
desarrollo de nuevas tecnologías a la
cura de enfermedades y a entender mejor
las amenazas globales que ocurren en
nuestro mundo el conocimiento tiene un
valor enorme es un valor prácticamente
ilimitado es un valor tan real y tan
tangible como el universo mismo gracias